foreign
oh yeah okay so this should be working
now
okay so hello to whoever's there I don't
think there's many people there today
for the beginning of the Q a there's a
weird lag in my video and so it might
take a while for me to notice
the questions in the chat
but uh yeah we'll see how that goes
all right and so a few announcements
before we start as some of you know I
was in um
in London
for um
I was in London for the uh for the last
week with Jordan Peterson and uh it was
pretty it's pretty wild pretty I mean it
was pretty wild in the sense that it was
really interesting I went to an
interesting meeting with people that are
hoping to offer a different alternative
to uh the narrative let's say that we're
dealing with in terms on the world stage
which was which was fascinating and then
I was also on stage with him
at the Apollo Theater it's like three
three thousand five hundred people I
don't think I've ever been in front of
so many people which was uh which was
wild
um and a few other things you'll see we
did a conversation with Muhammad hijab I
don't know if that's going to come out
we'll see we had it was an interesting
discussion
hopefully that will be made public as
well but maybe not we'll see
and uh so in the next few weeks so first
of all apologies again for people who've
been struggling to sign in to the
website
it's a frustrating thing that that is
going on but we're we we're going to um
we're going to launch a new website I we
hope in a few weeks like mid-october at
the you know is what we're seeing to be
aiming for uh and so because of it it's
just the energy to fix the current
website seems like it's not there so
hopefully when we get to to the website
all of this will will be settled and
things will be in a good in a good uh
situation
so um so yeah so yeah so let's go let's
start and so as people know
um
um for those who support me on patreon
or through PayPal on the website they uh
people can ask questions in advance if
for people who give a certain amount and
so that's how we get the questions and
then and then those that show up on the
chat I also will answer a question in uh
in the chat as well
so let's see let's start with the
question in the chat actually it says
why is identity an invisible Center a
story signified both from An Origin
above
it to which it returns and from its
outer product from which it departs as
well as allow and exist for offspring
um your question is is it super clear
but yes the the identity is an invisible
Center that's the best way to understand
it
because it's something which cannot be
found found in the elements that
constitute the identity but exist let's
say above Beyond it or the man in which
they come together
um and so that's the way to to uh to uh
understand the center
all right let's start with the symbolic
word website
so David Flores asks I've been thinking
about Authority for a while now it was
excited to see your left and right hand
videos
one aspect of authority that I feel I
often
I feel often gets forgotten is control
of power or domain
specifically not using the power you
have just because you can exercise
Authority or power doesn't mean you have
to or will at all times in your recent
videos on the right and left hand I felt
like the crossing over you were
describing is something like this when
the right doesn't exercise it's power it
looks like the left and vice versa
does this line up with your ideas and if
so could you elaborate on it um
yeah I'm not sure no I'm not sure it
lines up with my with my ideas
especially that I've been talking about
how there's a difference between
Authority and power let's say at least
that's the way that I describe it and so
if you're if you're kind of dealing with
that then I'm struggling to see
um
yeah I'm starting to see what that means
so sorry David
so I hope I'm gonna be okay during this
q a because since I got back from London
I've been sleeping like 12 hour days
every day and I'm really struggling to
like for some reason to like get back on
top of things
so hopefully that uh that won't affect
too much the discussion
so Benjamin would
ask as a polyglot what is your sense of
how English grammar and vocabulary shape
contemporary discourse I've heard that
English and Latin both have a tendency
to reify Concepts that Greek and other
Continental languages are less prone to
but I can't evaluate these claims if
true how significant a problem is that
it is it that English is a lingua
Francois of both science and the
internet
well English is definitely
I mean I thought about this English is
definitely something like um
something like the language of the end
and and because it
it seems to be very uh open to to
multiplicity like it seems to to be able
to be able to absorb anything like to
absorb you know the dramatic languages
but also the Latin languages and you
know whatever works seems to be able to
be absorbed into English and so on the
one on the one hand it definitely it
makes it
a very powerful language
uh because it kind of
because it it can it can just absorb
things and so it seems to it seems that
like English culture in general like a
kind of Anglo culture in general seems
to be pretty good at finding the balance
as it absorbs different things you know
that's I guess that's part of what
English History is about you know all
these different groups coming in and
taking over
um and so so language has that English
definitely has that characteristic but
it also it's interesting because because
of that characteristic it also has a
kind of richness in terms of
possibilities that other languages don't
because it often will have
in like so in English you'll often have
both the Germanic you know Anglo-Saxon
word and then the Latin word and this so
you have a lot of vocabulary and it and
it's very different you know the German
the kind of anglo-saxon words and the
Latin words are very different
um
so um so it's definitely interesting for
sure as someone who's bilingual
it's it can especially someone who knows
French can make you it can make you look
like you're smarter in English because
you your normal words in French are the
Latin words and so they it makes you it
can make you sound like you're really
smart because in English some of the
Latin words are usually a little more a
snooty or something like they're they're
more uh
they're they're more uh
they seem to sound smarter but for
French they're just a normal word so
it's uh it gives you an advantage there
hopefully
hopefully I hopefully that uh yeah but I
have noticed that I've noticed that but
sometimes I use a word which is just a
normal word to me but it comes it comes
from French and then people will react
as if I used a really fancy word it's
like well maybe in English it's a fancy
word but I don't think it's that fancy
in French
um
all right so Shane Carlton asked what is
the proper way for a lay member of an
organization to help Orient the head to
problems that are rising in the
organization
the main problem I'm seeing is the
significant infiltration of
non-traditional Christian values into a
Christian organization
and how to combat it
yeah it's very difficult I mean we're in
a difficult situation especially in
terms of Christianity
um
and so I think that I think that you
definitely need to
I think the best way to understand it is
you need to live those out on your own
that's the first thing
um and then you also need to
communicate it clearly to the the people
in in power the people that are in
charge you can do it a few times in
different ways
and in this particular time I think that
at some point if if it gets too bad
um
it's probably best to to go like it's
probably best to leave that organization
um
I know that I know that that that's at
least the what's important is at least
not to try to cause some kind of
to kind of have a revolutionary attitude
within the Christian organization and
not try to
to uh let's say upend the leadership but
at this point it's at least try to find
another Parish like at least another
Parish where things aren't so bad
depending on what church you're part of
but uh yeah it's a difficult uh it's a
difficult question
all right let's keep going
all right so Lance Whitehorse says can
we understand Nation initiation as
embodiment I'm curious about the use of
ritual to sanctify an initiation of a
person into a member of the tribe
uh I mean I wouldn't see it as an
embodiment I would see it as
definitely a way of joining yeah I mean
of joining to the body so of course
initiation is a way to
to make the transition between the
outside and the inside that tends to be
at least one of the functions of
initiation at least uh that is
definitely what circumcision is and also
what baptism is
um and so so yeah so it can it related
to joining into a body
let's say
all right and so Corey kobal asks can
you talk about the symbolism of soldiers
or Warriors they have monster
characteristics and so maybe belong on
the periphery defending the church but
also have a proper place in society
and so
um yeah you you definitely have a point
that's I often talk about that
let me just check something for two
seconds oh we're good
um
there's something about soldiers that
people that stand on the wall that they
they actually have a lot in common with
your enemy and they almost have to have
something in common with your enemy in
order for them to be soldiers and so
they tend to represent
they represent order in the sense that
they're connected to the center but they
also represent the periphery in the
sense that they like yeah they're the
wall on the the side they have they hold
the weapons
um
and and so
and so that is something to to think
about in terms of how they
how they manifest themselves as as
protection you know a policeman has more
in common with the criminal or a PO or a
a prison guard has more income income in
common with the inmate than with normal
people in society there's something
about that which is true in terms of
soldiers
um and so that's why you can kind of
understand
what happens sometimes with the question
of mercenaries and the problem of
mercenaries
um the idea of soldiers for hire and all
that but there's definitely uh
they definitely have a place in society
but it's a difficult place it's always a
difficult place
all right James orange asks can you
explain the significance of the
following passage Luke 11 24 26
when the unclean Spirit has gone out of
a man he passed it through waterless
places seeking rest
and finding none he says I will return
to my house from which I came
and when he comes he finds it swept and
put in order then he goes and brings
seven other Spirits more evil than
himself and they enter and dwell there
and the last state of that man becomes
worse than the first
thank you for everything you are doing
and so this is this is about the problem
of
of
the problem of
the need for Spirit like or the need for
principality there needs to be things
that manage you or that you know inhabit
your house you could say it that way the
way that the scripture talks about it so
it's talking about the problem of
wanting to get rid of certain bad habits
or certain bad aspects of reality but
not replacing them with something better
so if you don't replace a bad habit with
with something better or worship or or
just something better I mean of course
worship is the ultimate version of that
but you know if you if you if you don't
replace a bad habit with a better habit
then you're actually opening yourself up
for
for uh rush like a rush in of of the
passion you had with seven more with it
so I've used this example before in
terms of a diet you know if you diet and
you're not careful and you you kind of
push yourself to the extreme and you
just stop eating the things that you
like and you don't have anything to
replace it like you you don't you're not
thinking of how to replace you're just
removing your your the things that you
you tend to go to then you're gonna
binge and you're gonna find yourself
eating way more than before and it's the
same with a lot of the passions you you
know you have to be
you have to be careful when you try to
eliminate something bad uh because
that's because of that
all right and so
foreign
so Cormac Jones as greetings Jonathan
given what you've said about bathrooms
and identity would you further say
there's something about menstruation
that would train a woman to perceive
what builds up
on her uterine walls
dude as beyond the boundaries of her
bodily identity such that and he's
zygote that is planted there should be
intuitively perceived as not her body
is there an argument to be made from
emergent natural law that life begins at
conception an argument that is that does
not rely on Revelation emanating from
above like the gospel story of
annunciation
is there a way to divvy up the
phenomenology of childbearing so as to
identify where the mother's life ends
and the child's life begins or is that
like the beginning of a life a mystery
where our minds cannot tread without
Revelation from above
a noble by natural law
dude
I've never thought about what you're
saying there I never thought about what
you're saying
it's a very strange perception that you
had
that the idea that because
a woman ejects monthly some aspect that
something that's inside her as an
outside
then then that would be like a pre
we tend to see it at the opposite of
that like we tend to see it as a as a
kind of side effect of
of fertility you know and something like
a failed a failed Union that's why if
there's no Union then there's like a
residue which is produced by the failed
Union that's tends to be the way that
that at least I understand it so
so I've never really thought about about
what you're saying in the way that
you're saying it
um
and so I think that the problem
like the problem of what you're asking
is
is really a problem in a world where
where child
having children is not the ultimate
value
and so the question of when exactly
Life Begins and so we could say
conception you know in some ways I'd
rather say that but there's a matter in
which that question becomes
a question only if you think that you
would want to to not have children
but in a world where having children is
a blessing and it's something
that people want then
you know it's like you wouldn't even try
to ask that question you'd just be happy
that that that
you're going to have a child and and
that you know that a new life is going
to come from you and so and so I think
that that's my answer you know it's like
I think that that's my answer
and if you're in a situation where you
shouldn't have gotten pregnant let's say
and where getting pregnant is
is uh is is a social embarrassment or is
a is a moral problem
then that's probably the reason why you
would ask that question and so in the
very
let's say and even in a world where like
in a world where a child bearing would
be very valuable you can understand what
someone would want to ask this question
would be in a moment where they they got
pregnant through some some other
means that aren't through through
through marriage and so so I think that
that's my best answer is that
is that
if we value life and we value the Next
Generation and we think that that's very
precious
then we won't try to answer that
question in a technical way so that
doesn't give you a lot of stuff in terms
of legal and and and in terms of of
defending the the the question legally
but the problem with defending the
question legally is also difficult in a
world where people don't care about
about about children and so
it's like how are you going to how are
you going to change
you know how are you going to change
make let's say make abortion illegal in
a world where everybody thinks that
that having a child is not the most
valuable thing
you can do it but
it's going to be very difficult I mean
it seems like there needs to be a deeper
transformation
for that to truly be uh reverse let's
say
foreign
era asks hi Jonathan God bless you
you've once you've said what the Jesus
manifests all the true patterns of The
Twelve Apostles also participate in that
by manifesting patterns that will fill
the world
I've come to understand how Peter and
Paul manifest that in their symbolism
and in the story of the church via the
left and right hand patterns especially
in the west you've also talked about
talk sometimes about Judas as a type of
antichrist but how do the other Apostles
fulfill the world like that
what is the symbolism related to them
also when will the universal series
sorry when will the universal series
with Richard Roland return this series
need needs a great comeback yeah we're
definitely going to start that very soon
Richard was traveling he went um
who's traveling with Father Andrew uh uh
they make actually and so you know
they're back and uh so we'll start soon
I think we even have a date I don't even
remember when it is though
um so how did the other 12 Apostles
fulfill the world like that and so it's
interesting because
you've got a point like a lot of the 12
apostles the symbolism of The Twelve
Apostles is seems like it's lost or that
we don't know much about them there are
certain Apostles that definitely have
um
that definitely have some tradition that
importance for example like Saint Andrew
he he is the one who kind of evangelizes
the uh the the you know so much of the
world and he's shown with his Wild Hair
he kind of goes out into all these these
places you also have uh of course the
Apostle Thomas who goes to India and has
all these Traditions related to him in
India
um and then there are a few others but
it's true that most of them seem to to
kind of be lost to us but you can
understand it
just in some ways as as a cosmic image
as the 12 you know and so you you have
the 12
months or the 12th you know the 12 signs
of the of the zodiac you have the 12
tribes of Israel and so that's the way
to understand it it's basically thinking
of let's say moving out from the center
if you look at if you look at the
description of how the camp of Israel
was supposed to be set with the
Tabernacle in the center and with the
tribes kind of all around it all these
these 12
and a half tribe or whatever all around
the the the
Tabernacle you kind of have to
understand it that way so it's like an
extension of Christ into the world when
I imagine instead of the Tabernacle you
have the entire Cosmos as the place and
that's what you see in the image of
Pentecost when you see the 12 Flames
kind of spread out on the disciples but
imagining it like spread out into the
whole world so that's a way to
understand it but it's true that some of
the specific
the specific especially the disciples
especially the 12 like some of that
symbolism is lost
um for sure so
all right
all right and so
Tobias
lundgrist asked when Adam ate from the
fruit of the tree he blames the woman
for his sin who in turn blamed the
serpent that's the serpent became the
first scapegoat Jesus reversed this by
turning himself into the ultimate final
scapegoat and took the sins of the world
upon his shoulders is it reasonable to
assume that if Eve had not blamed the
serpent then God would not have cursed
the Beast and our animal nature would
not have fallen interesting likewise if
Adam and I blame Eve then we then she
would not have been weighed down by the
curse either and our feminine
imagination would not lead us to
straight thanks highly appreciate your
work and so I think that this these
these kind of speculations they're not
that useful
because you kind of have to understand
it as a single move
right as a single move that is that is
the move of taking Divinity for yourself
means that you're acting right you're
you take Divinity for yourself and pride
and so that is almost the same in its
very nature
as let's say
blaming the other for your problems and
so you know if you're not God right and
so if you if you want to be like God and
you you eat the fruit that is
that will make you you know
if you take for yourself the idea that
you are going to be like God then
what are you going to do and so you have
to you have to blame others for your
for your problems
um
and so you're right though that Christ
definitely inverts the whole story and
inverts the process
because he does also eat the fruit but
he also takes the blame and so even
though he's innocent so it's like really
the opposite of the story of of Adam and
Eve Adam and Eve take the fruit and then
blame the others for the consequence of
eating the fruit uh and are guilty right
of taking uh of disobeying and so Christ
takes the fruit in obeying the will of
God as you see in the Garden of
Gethsemane the night before it's
important to see that that's what's
going on there as well that he is
actually obeying the will of God by
eating the fruit and then accepting the
consequences of that and dying so it
really is a flipping of the Genesis
story
in many many
ways and so
all right
so Mark Johnson asked what is Mercy and
Grace
and so they're not exactly the same
they're related to each other I guess
but they're not exactly the same it's
the same also when people talk about
rigor and Justice they're not exactly
the the same
they are they are kind of related
um
the way that I see Mercy is mostly about
the notion of of
letting go right or not
holding against someone
and therefore not holding what you could
hold against them and so basically
letting letting people come to you
despite that you know and so you could
say that Mercy is when
Mercy is when you you know someone does
something like someone does something
against you and you would have every
right to be angry and would you just
kind of Let It Go in order to to bring
that person in communion with you that's
the way that I understand it Grace in
terms of
especially in terms of Orthodoxy is is
very different right Grace
at least in Orthodox theology is really
the manner in which
god let's say reveals himself to us
that is it is you know we talk about the
relationship between grace and God's
energies the idea that
it is the it is the the presence of God
in all things and the presence of God
in the world is is is through his grace
through his
through his
the man in which he's hiding behind all
things is the best way to say that
all right so Yvonne says there's some
problems with the Stream
hmm
hopefully it's okay
it might that might be why there are not
many people
online usually they're more people
so I don't know what's going on
hopefully it's okay
all right I'm gonna continue all right
so I'm gonna move to questions from
subscribe star
well checks asked dear Jonathan have you
ever visited a Catholic
actually let's see
let's see if I have messages from people
telling me there's a problem
all right I don't see
don't see any messages for now so
all right okay so let's go to subscribe
sorry just one question on subscribe
star well checks asked dear Jonathan
have you ever visited a Catholic mass in
the old shooting teen right can you say
something about the symbolism there for
example using the Latin language and why
it may be a danger or not to change this
whole liturgy thank you so much for your
work and so yes I have been to a
traditionalist Catholic master I enjoyed
it I think it was beautiful I've been to
several
um and I you know I kind of understand
or sympathize to a certain extent with
the the the Latin in the sense that
there's this there's a sense in which at
least in the west Latin is the language
which kind of holds the West together
which makes it
something you know and so I can
understand why some people hold on to
the Latin Mass but I also don't believe
that
you necessarily need to have the Liturgy
in in
Latin for it to be valuable I think it
is valuable to understand the words of
the Liturgy you know and so that's why I
do prefer
it's funny because it seems like in in
the Catholic church you can it's like
you can't have you can't have
um
you have one or the other you either
either have the old right or the Trinity
right in Latin or you have the Vatican 2
right in your language but for some
reason there doesn't exist
you know a uh
a tridentine version in your local
language which which is interesting I
don't know an Orthodoxy translation has
always been an important part of
of the church and of
oh and and you know because when they
converted the Russians they immediately
translated the Liturgy in slavonic and
then the same with all the other
countries you know when they they when
they would be evangelize the Liturgy
would be translated immediately but not
immediately sometimes it took a bit of
time but it would be translated
ultimately
so yeah I tend to prefer that myself
all right
all right so we're moving to patreon
so hephaestos is sad little hammer
asks hi Jonathan I don't understand what
glory is
okay
for example you oppose death with Glory
I don't oppose it I say it's they're the
same what did I say the death is
different from Glory
why not oppose death with life I asked
my priest and he said something I need
you to explain
he said glory is another word for the
uncreated energy which is God himself
his presence that we can experience also
called Grace glorious often used to
describe God's visible presence
manifested his light cloud
Etc can you perhaps interpret what he
said for a weak little foreigner like me
thank you so much a weak little
Foreigner
um
so he's saying the stream is quiet I see
someone saying the stream is quiet
to check something
um
let me make it a little bit louder
hopefully this will help all right I
don't know
I don't know it's weird this stream is
weird this this time had some weird
issues okay
so
so your priest is right and so of course
your piece is right but he is
he's talking about the glory of God and
so of course you're not God you also
have a glory every you know living
things have glories uh but the glory of
God is very specific because God is the
source of all things so you could
understand Glory as something like the
overflowing of you
and so you you know as a person there
you have extensions of you which
overflow from you and so you have
manifestations of you in the world
um and so that glory is your reputation
That Glory is the stories people tell
about you that glory is the things you
do it's your Works your works it's uh
the things you leave behind you know
it's the the uh you know the the things
you've created all those things
participate in your glory so you can
understand it really as
as an extension
of your being
uh out in the world okay so so that's
why you know you you know it's like an
athlete wins a competition and that's
his glory he has Glory so we we we
glorify him we give him a medal we we
add things to him in order to so that we
can see his his glory okay now
in the sense of God
it's more complicated because God is Not
let's say God is the source of all
things and so you can understand the
glory of God
as the manner in which God fills all
things so it's an over if you can
understand like an overflowing of God
it's the works of God it's the way in
which God manifests himself in the world
it's it's everything that that that
makes
a sea god or encounter God okay uh but
the idea in Orthodox theology is that
that glory and that Grace
like we mentioned before in the early
question is not separate from God it's
actually God himself and what it is
because God is the source of all things
it becomes the underlying reality of all
things
and so God is hiding through his glory
so all the world is full of his glory
right you've heard that before the the
world is full of God's glory that is the
world is an expression of God of God
that is God created the world and so it
is full of his glory and His glory
underlies it and is actually causing it
so that's maybe the difference between
God's glory and our Glory uh but you can
understand both as as
as the same and so the way to understand
it so you can if you look at the way
that it's described in scripture you can
kind of understand it
is that
if so all these overflowing things
if they are connected to God then they
are God's glory if they get cut off from
God
and they're seen as having being in
themselves or having value in themselves
then they become idols
okay they become so so
you know
because we we we aren't there aren't we
aren't linking them properly to their
true Source they aren't vehicles for us
to see through them the the the god
present in the world and so that's true
for God
okay but then it's true also for you
that is
if you're overflowing that is if the
works you do
are not done
ultimately in the service of God you
know in the proper alignment with God
then that those Works which are your
glory will be dead
right and you can understand so many
things about how the
you know in the the Epistles how this is
discussed it's like on the one hand
Saint Paul says things like you have to
run the race you know win the win the
race get the crown all that kind of
language and then and right away like
immediately late a bit later he'll say
things like you know works are dead
their works are
they they have no value in themselves
okay and so you can understand it
similarly to the man in which God's
glory fills the world it's like your
glory
can fill the world to a certain extent
but if that Glory isn't in service of
God then it becomes death it becomes an
image of your death and so
the image the ultimate image of
receiving a crown so you receive Glory
on your head but then you offer that
Crown to God so it's like if you offer
your crown your glory to God
then then that Glory that is that's the
only way that the glory you receive has
any value
and so it's like a paradox but not
really it's a paradox in the sense that
whatever Glory you have only Finds Its
value if it is offered up to God but if
you try to keep your glory for yourself
then it becomes dead letter it becomes
dead and becomes dead works okay
um
so hopefully that's helpful I I
think I've got it right
all right so Matthew Jones says hi
Jonathan I've heard that some Orthodox
priest say Jesus didn't fulfill
all the Old Testament prophecies as his
first coming and will be fulfilled at
the second coming
it seems crazy that all Old Testament
prophecies wouldn't have been fulfilled
at his first coming maybe they don't
know how to interpret the Old Testament
prophecies correctly since they think
they haven't been fulfilled your
thoughts
um
and so there's definitely like there's a
mysterious
aspect to that the West beta will
understand it and this it might might
seem like a cop-out to some people but
that's what it's going to be is that
there's a sense in which Christ on the
cross
all is finished like all is done on the
cross
and and there's a sense in which all is
done something like in
like a seed like everything contained in
the center
it's like everything is accomplished and
now all that has to happen is it has to
kind of unfold
and so
so that's the the way that I tend to
understand it
and so maybe in that sense you can get
it you can get a feeling like well some
of the things said in the Old Testament
will happen at the second coming but the
second coming is just an extension
of
the crucifixion and Resurrection at
least that's the way that I see it
um
so
so I mean because Christ himself you
know talks about
you know the the the coming of the son
of man and the Judgment of the world and
all these things and so it seems like he
is pointing to something further but I
do think that that has happened
that happened on the cross at least in
seed form that's why we have the good
and the bad thief on the cross as an
image of that that the Judgment of the
living and the dead
um
already happened uh which is difficult
in terms of in terms of you know I I
understand how that would be difficult
for you know just kind of secular people
to uh
to understand so that's as much as I'm
going to say about that
all right so undying Nephilim that's
your name undying Nephilim tells me that
the sound is much better so I'm happy to
hear that on dime Nephilim but we also
do hope that you will die Nephilim
not you personally but you know you're
you're uh you're uh
your avatar or whatever so Anton o
Anderson says hi Jonathan I hope you're
doing well I asked a couple of months
ago about the correlation between the
weight of Simon's gold and the number of
the beasts which are both 666. I also
found that in a Muslim tradition the
beasts of the Earth has the Ring of
Solomon and marks and Believers by
destroying their noses
hmm
I know you're understandably hesitant to
talk too much about the mark but can you
talk about the symbolism of Solomon's
apostasy with him owning an excess
amount of gold and worshiping his
foreign Gods yes you've got you've
understand it correctly you understand
it correctly it seems like what happened
with to Solomon is that he
he in his wisdom right in his Earth in
his wisdom he came to a point where he
wanted to account for everything and
that that has to do with the idea of
counting the remainder of of his gold
but then it also has to do with
worshiping foreign gods and so it's like
it's as if
you want to account for the for the
margin you want to account for the
excluded within your your religious
system
and so I think that that's definitely
the idea that we talk about when we talk
about the Beast as this the system which
tries to account for everything
and in doing so ends up leveling
everything or inverting everything in a
weird way
um and so yeah you've got you've got but
this is interesting the idea
destroying their noses
think about that interesting
so who wrote says Dear Jonathan I really
enjoyed your video about Sir going and
the Green Knight I have been struggling
with one aspect of the story at the
answer going appears to give his
confession to the Green Knight
sorry
suggesting that he takes the role of a
priest
or even Persona Christie
the poet emphasizes the devilish quality
of the green Chapel which from the
description seems to be a dolman
but is still referred to as a chapel
this seems a strange mixture of pagan
and Christian elements
any help with this would be appreciated
so I've never thought about
the idea that he would be
confessing
to the green night as a priest but you
do have a point that for sure the the
strange idea of the green Chapel
um
so there definitely is
like the whole story
of the Green Knight has to do with how
to deal with the stranger how to deal
with this with the strange
and so it would definitely that's why it
would definitely have something of
paganism in it
and the notion of how to deal with the
strange appears right at the outset of
course with this strange monster which
appears in the in King Arthur's Court
but then it also goes on later in terms
of the idea of him being a guest in a
foreign Nobles castle and his strange
wife trying to seduce him you know this
is all biblical imagery of the
stranger's wife trying to seduce you you
can imagine Joseph in the house of party
far you can imagine Solomon warning his
his child warning his son about the
foreign woman you know whose feet go
down to Shale you know whose lips are as
smooth as honey but his whose lips go
down to death
um and so this is all what's kind of
going on there and so
this is also represented in the green
belt itself as this strange
rim of this strange periphery
which acts as a supplement and protects
you right and so there's a there's a
relationship I mentioned this before
with between this idea of the of the
adding of the strange skins on Adam and
Eve like adding of this of the strange
as a layer around the outside so all of
this is what the Green Knight is about
um and so that there's there there's
definitely something about the green
Chapel which is
probably something like what you're
saying probably something of uh
ambiguous Chapel something about an
ambiguous
holy place that isn't Christian that
isn't Pagan but really is you know
the liminal this liminal space that the
whole story is about and the question is
how
can
Gawain
how should going act in that that world
um but in terms of the idea of
confessing that's interesting like I
definitely have to to to think about it
and but it turns like in the end the
surprising thing is that it's as if it's
like a trick the whole thing is a trick
right the the the the
the whole process was there to test
whether or not he would remain uh true
and faithful
um so yeah so but there's definitely
still things to think about with that
story because it's a it's a very complex
story
in terms of symbolism
right so Joe Gallegos says hi Jonathan
I'm a CPA and I've been trying to
understand what taxes represent in
respect to symbology any ideas so taxes
are really just sacrifices they're just
good old sacrifices you know you you
take your what you have that's valuable
and you give it up towards a higher
participation so you give it to the
state and the state then offers back
something right you give up the money of
taxes then the state offers protection
identity cohesion
um you know laws rules all the things
that bind us so in order for the state
to bind us it has to take from us some
potential
um to form its and form its body and and
so we become its body but it's
symbolized but not just symbolized but
but symbolizing the sense of
concentrated into us giving up value up
the hierarchy so that so that we can
participate in um
in the common projects in whatever
common project that we're involved with
so when you know I know some people are
like death to taxes type people but I
really don't see that as a Christian
position really it's just not possible
because
because without taxes you can't exist as
a common body without giving up and and
it's the same with the church if you
don't tithe through your church if you
don't give money to your church you're
not part of the church I'm sorry to tell
you like you have to give money
and I know this sounds like it could
sound crass it's not crass at all you
have to give up potential
towards the towards a higher being in
order to participate it in it and so
it's not just money obviously you can
imagine that you also have to give
attention and you have to give energy
and you have to give work let's say up
uh you know all those things are can be
traded with with money you you can
imagine that uh in some groups instead
of let's say giving money up to the
state you could say something like
everybody has to give a week of their
time say a group it's like everybody has
to give a week of their time or
everybody has to give so many hours to
the group in order for in order to kind
of bind us and make us exist as a group
but no matter what it is you have to
give up potential for higher beings to
be able to exist
so undying Nephilim says don't worry I
regret the name all these years later
that's hilarious
it's okay we love you anyways on
diagonal and we know you're on the right
path
we hope at least you're on the right
path
all right so Justin damanski says
greeting Jonathan what are your thoughts
on the internet
intentional use of symbolism to
manipulate people I'm referring to
primary to actors within the marketing
and advertising industry and their
scientific approach to utilizing
symbolic language for commercial
political or even experimental reasons
yes you have a point and this is
interesting because
there's a relationship between the
discovery of symbolic structures from a
psychoanalytic uh level because like
Freud and Jung had really good
intuitions like Freud sometimes I think
is he's almost like a he's always like
an antichrist figure and don't don't
freak out because I use that term but in
the sense that he has like upside down
symbolism so a lot of the things
actually that Freud says in terms of
you know certain sexual symbolism that
he encounters and dreams and all this
stuff if you flipped it back it actually
can become a kind of image of
of uh of higher symbolism let's say
um and so what's interesting is that a
lot of the advertisement symbolism that
we see today in uh
in a different company started with
Freud's nephew Edward Bernays who wrote
the book propaganda and tried to use
uh psychoanalytic symbolism in order to
in advertisement and not just an
advertisement but also in statecraft and
in uh and in
um and in psyop operations or psyop
operations both within the country and
and I imagine on the enemies of course
what Bernays did for the government is
not known but he did work for several
agencies in the government
um and so you're right I mean
it's it's a it's a dangerous thing you
know it's like uh
the problem of having a little bit of
knowledge and having power
it's kind of like you can imagine uh
a magician in the old sense or a
sorcerer who has just enough
spiritual intuition like just enough
spiritual knowledge to be able to use it
against others but not enough to
understand that what they're doing is
is leading to destruction or is leading
to to uh
to problems down the line so
all right and so Alex silento asked us
some of the question so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna answer the the other one
so Reuben korff asks hi Jonathan I have
for a while been considering the
significance of the enokian Fallen
Angels
have both sexual relations with human
women and then also teach them various
technical art and skills and some Jewish
and Christian writings only one of these
two events is discussed but in one Enoch
it seems very significant that they are
connected somehow closely together with
this in mind as well as the prevalence
of internet porn
what can we say about the relationship
between sex and technology and or
technique
yeah there's definitely a relationship
there's a direct relationship because
Techni is an increase in power
for desire that's what Techni is that is
it increases our power
but it increases our power
most often in the direction of our
desire because the desire for power
itself is
let's say
problematic and so so there's definitely
a direct relationship between
desire you know technology the increase
in it and then ultimately leading to
something like uh pornography
um
yeah I don't know what they'll say it
seems like it that's pretty that that's
pretty clear
yeah hopefully that makes sense
all right and so Cameron Dixon says hi
Jonathan what are the symbolism of the
three languages Latin Greek and Aramaic
that appear
on the sign above Christ on the cross
um I mean I think that it's interesting
because it links worlds together I think
that that's probably the best way to
understand it it's as if you could say
that
you know there was a declaration that he
is the king you know and that
declaration is done both in the local
Semitic language
the Latin language which was the
language of the Romans but then also
Greek which was
the lingua Franca of the whole region
you know the kind of thing the Hellenic
the Hellenistic culture that bound all
these Mediterranean uh these
Mediterranean cultures together and so I
think that that's really what that's
about in terms of symbolism
so Christian Class asked hello Jonathan
do you have any symbolic insight into
the words given to saintsilon by our
Lord
keep thy mind in hell and despair not
and so
first of all it's important to
understand that when it says hell I
think it really means it means death
Shale like keep your mind in death
and despair not
I think this has to do with the idea
that if you die on purpose then you
won't die accidentally and so you know
if you if you slay your desires
if you keep yourself in death in that
sense where if you let if you don't
if you're able to put to death yourself
and your desires then
that is the best position because then
you will not die and then you will
actually find a strange hope
because you won't have the actual
despair which is which is
which is attachment to those desires
right which is
let's say undo attachment to all these
things that
that bind us and so I think that that's
that's the image
yeah and so you can unders you could see
it if we said it the opposite way
right if you could say something like
if I would say something like keep your
mind on your desires
and you will despair
right then you can kind of understand it
it's harder maybe to understand the
opposite which is
keep your mind in death and despair not
and you won't despair
hope that makes sense
so Marcus David says what's the symbolic
meaning of Lucifer Morningstar being
voted the sickest man alive by women
really you mean the character you mean
the character on uh like the Neil Gaiman
character I guess there's a series
Netflix series on that
I mean whatever dude it's not surprising
I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what to tell you
that's the world we live in all right
Brandon Wyrick says you sometimes
describe the cross as a place where
Heaven and Earth meet isn't this a
quality comment at some level to all
symbols does this make this cross a meta
symbol or recursive symbol is Christ
like symbol man yes I do think that the
cross is something of a medicine ball or
like the symbol of symbols definitely
definitely so I think the cross
is definitely one of the most primordial
images like I mean in the sense that
it's
it's what our perception is made of you
know
and so I think that it's very very
important
so you can understand like the point as
being the essence
of that but you don't see the point that
you don't really see it the cross makes
the point visible this intersection and
so
yeah yeah I do think it is a meta symbol
so X Perez asks in the life of say Moses
the black it is said that sometime after
his conversion he was descended upon by
robbers whom he subdued and brought to
the Elders of his Monastery effectively
bringing them to repentance Summit
contrarily said from Sarah of upon being
robbed laid down his arms and allowed
himself to be beaten only later
interceding on behalf of his assailants
to the judge at their trial
how could these two responses
to the same stimulus relate to the
Divergent symbolism of the right and the
left thanks again for all your wonderful
content
such a great story man that story same
Moses
such a great story because it's like in
the story it should suggests that he
that he didn't hurt them I guess he's
like he subdued them you know he has
this huge Thug
so
no I I think that both of them are I
think both of them are are uh are good
if I remember correctly and I might be
wrong but I think that there's also a
sense in which Saint Moses was
protecting others this is also something
which
is very is different in terms of
understanding
you know the idea that you
that you you'd say wouldn't defend
yourself but you would defend others
uh and I think if I remember correctly
that's part of the story is that it
would those robbers were not just there
to Rob him but we're there to rob the
monastery and to rob the other monks and
so Saint Moses you know
just subdued them
it's a great story and it also kind of
shows
you know it it it it shows the nature of
say Moses you know who is this protector
in many ways you know he's a criminal
he's a robber you know he he kills the
dog and so he becomes like the protector
for those who who uh
for those who
um want a little hint on on God's dog we
suggest that in the story which is why
what he doesn't actually kill the dog
but when the dog dies in the story of
the first book you know because of the
the the thieves that kill the the dog
then Christopher replaces the dog in the
story and so there's a little bit of
that in the stair of Saint Moses where
he kind of becomes the guard dog and has
to deal with issues
um
with the issues but then ultimately in
the end of his story my understanding is
that the last in the very end of his
story the way he dies is that he
actually lets himself be killed by
robbers
if I remember correctly so so that part
of seraphim is also there in the story
of uh of Saint Moses
so BJ BJ Santa says hi Jonathan and
synoptic gospels there seems to be a
pattern around the Transfiguration
first there is a confession of Peter
Jesus's prediction of his death and the
fall of Peter then there is the
Transfiguration
and there is the healing of the boy
is there a deeper link that means these
must go together thank you and God bless
father Jerome Santa Maria
so
there's something there someone recently
oh man I wish I could remember
his name there's a wonderful priest I
was having a discussion with him
recently
um
and he uh
oh man I wish I remember his name right
now and he he was able to help me
understand an aspect of the
Transfiguration that I never understood
and I think it's related to all of this
it's that so the the Transfiguration is
is we understand that it happens on the
Feast of the Tabernacles and if he's the
Tabernacles were when the the Israelites
would would make tense for themselves
and live in tents for a certain amount
of time in order to remember the
um The Exodus uh when they lived in
tents in the desert but there's also a
sense of which that it's related to the
Tabernacle in the sense of the Holy
Tabernacle too
and so
so Saint Peter
so Saint Peter uh
Christ says he's going to die and Saint
Peter says you don't have to die and
then
Peter uh
Christ uh rebukes him right
um and then it's like in the
Transfiguration happens again but I
never seen it that way I never see it
either way but someone that the person
really made me this priest really made
me see it
Christ appears with Elijah and Moses and
and Peter says
basically Peter says I'm going to build
the church that's what he's saying when
he says we'll make tense for you he's
saying we will make the tents for you we
will make the Tabernacle for you because
you are the glory of God we will make
the Tabernacle for you and then Christ
says no
and what he's saying is something like I
will
you know it's like
you will it's like I will build my
church I will make my church you will be
part of that
but always know that I am making my
church and it's like that's the sin of
Peter it's like he he tends to think
that he's the one he tends to think that
he's the church and or that he's got it
and Christ has to remind him like yes
I'm making I'm doing it through you but
as soon as you forget that it's through
through me that you're able to do it
then I rebuke you and it's like man
there's a there's a very powerful
mystery about the Christian church in
that you know there's a very powerful
mystery so so I think that definitely in
terms of the in terms of the fall of
Peter before of the rebuking Peter and
the Transfiguration there's like
there's definitely a relationship
between between those two you know
it's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so
yeah good stuff I mean it it's pretty
powerful but I'm not sure about the
healing of the boy though I'd have to
think about that I have to think about
the healing of the boy hopefully that
gives you a little bit of a hint of how
these seems to fit together in a very
beautiful way
all right so Garrett windner
says hello Jonathan where's your opinion
of you on using video games as the means
of culture creation it seems most
overtly Christian video games are
shallow and childish and video games as
a whole Hue towards centralism and time
wasting do you have any thoughts on on
how a video game could be useful in a
Christian sense and so I mean I think
video games can be useful to a certain
degree because they tend to have a
hierarchy and they tend to have a kind
of ladder of Ascension and and so you
can kind of understand hierarchy and
Ascension and transformation like
they're usually pretty shallow
Transformations but nonetheless like
especially if you think of uh like kind
of uh role-playing role you know RPG
games where you have a character that
that that has to acquire certain skills
and virtues and then ascends and
therefore Masters more domain as they
kind of Ascend that that hierarchy
um I think that that can help people
understand how uh how the world works
and how you know of course it's it's a
low version of that but I do think that
there's some interesting and just like
fantasy stories it seems like video
games because they're simplified worlds
they tend to have compressed symbolism
in them you know uh so so I think it can
be useful I think the problem is of
course that they're massively overused
and that they kind of take over and they
replace religion I guess for a certain
extent and you know seem to replace life
for some people so that's the danger of
them but you know
I don't think they're evil in themselves
all right so then DB says hello Jonathan
what is the symbolism of Ruth in the
Bible thank you for all your work keep
fighting the good fight and so
symbolism of Ruth in the Bible is the
symbolism of
the the strange potential that can be
included it has to do with what stranger
can be included inside what what's what
aspects of the of the strange and of the
the foreign can be included and so
you know that's why
you know
all the similar there's so much
symbolism about about that like she
comes she you know she is uh she she's
the the
the stepdaughter of of uh
what's what's the name of uh Naomi who
me who says who's bitter so she's the
stepdaughter of the bitter like if you
know the bitter Waters these unfruitful
Waters and so she seems to be like a
bitter aspect but because she says your
God will be my God and because she
follows her stepmother even though she
didn't have to back to Israel then she's
connected she's connected to the center
and can be redeemed you could say or can
be can be well redeemed is the best way
to understand it can be redeemed and
brought into in on the inside even
though she is a a stranger and an
outsider and so but her symbolism like
the idea
that she is
um
I think she's gleaning right isn't she
even in the story um I might make a
mistake here
I want her to be gleaning in the story
like to be taking what's what's fallen
from the I think she's gleaming uh from
from that is she's a stranger gleaning
on the field uh and then she comes and
she uncovers the feet of uh
of Boaz and it's like the relationship
with the feet and the strange if you
remember you know the whole idea of the
feet and what they represent uh as the
limit of the body and they also they
they they are a stand-in for
other parts of the body like other let's
say uh
the parts of the body where the sun
doesn't what doesn't shine right that
those with the feet also kind of
represent and so she kind of uncovers
that and she uncovers his nakedness you
could say but in that case she's doing
it towards Redemption and not towards
Scandal so it's like a weird thing going
on there
and then ultimately she also represents
a glimmer of the return of of uh
the return of the the
the the these these stranger because
mobile the moabites are uh
I'm not sure oh man I'm I'm confused
about who the moabites were so sorry I I
need to check that to make sure that I
don't make an error in that but at least
it gives you a good idea like of who of
who uh
of who that
how that relates to uh the story Ruth
all right
all right so Manuel Montiel asks what is
the symbolism of excessive adornment and
how does this relate to nakedness
can there be excessive nakedness both
adornment and nakedness seem to have
their place in the church
certain icons of Saint Mark the setic is
naked but it's clearly far from
acceptable to be excessively adorned
versus naked
if I walk down the street thanks for
entertaining the oddly phrase questions
I mean there can be transgressive
nakedness if that's what you mean by
excessive nakedness and so there's a
nakedness of of Scandal we talk about
that I've talked about that a few times
where there's the idea of of uh
improperly
uh revealing the nakedness
your nakedness or the nakedness of
others and it usually has to do with it
kind of embarrassment and it it has to
do with the kind of uh
Scandal right and so the idea of like
participating in a scandal
is something like excessive nakedness
so it kind of shows you to the world
it has to do with like the idea of I
mean of course it's nakedness the idea
of public nakedness right of showing
being exposed like that's that could be
excessive nakedness where someone is
exposed his private sins or his private
thing are like exposed and so you see
their nakedness in a way that is
improper ultimately
because we all have those like we all
have our nakedness we all have our
scandals our sins or whatever and so and
so when you see someone someone's sins
are kind of exposed to the world I think
that would be something like excessive
nakedness
so Drew McMahon asks hi Jonathan can
explain why the sense is that Mary and
Joseph were traveling for
was important an aspect of the story of
Jesus's birth
I think that it has to do with
it has to do with this idea of
accounting for things you know it has a
little bit to do with the problem of
civilization or the problem of you know
this idea of the symbolism of the Beast
that we've talked about or the symbolism
of the number of the beasts and
accounting for all things
and so a census is
like in in scripture you're not supposed
to have a census like Tim David is
is is uh in the story of King David
there's like there's criticism about the
census which is not done properly
because it's dangerous to count things I
know this sounds weird it's like the
secular people will just freak out uh
it's dangerous because when you count
things you crystallize them because you
actually make them you fix them and so
when you do that you you can finalize
them you know if you count something you
fix it and you can finalize it and if
you do that
you know you're kind of accelerating
uh
accelerating it's shattering maybe is
the best way to kind of understand that
and so you could
you get I mean you are it's hard for
people to understand what I'm saying but
if you see it in excess you can maybe
understand it so it's like imagine
someone who is obsessed with
with all the details right someone who
is obsessed with every single detail
about something
and so if you become obsessed with all
the details and you don't leave fluidity
on the edge of of processes that you're
involved with you run the risk of
killing that thing like you can kill
something
do excessive attention and accounting
for detail okay uh so maybe that's a
better way for you to understand that so
you can under if you understand it and
it's and it's in its extreme which would
be something like
um
you know I'm uh I'm uh I'm on a
construction site and I ask for the guys
on my construction site to account for
every nail that they use and every screw
that they put in and I want them to come
to me in the end with an explanation of
how many nails they put in each board
and and and and where the boards were
and I want to account for all that it's
like I am going to kill this project I'm
going to destroy it and so now
understand that as the relationship
between accounting for things
and their ringing about their end you
can you can
bring about the end of something through
accounting
um and I think that that is what is
being
manifested in the notion of the census
it's like
yeah it's like Rome is Romans Rome is
it's coming to an end you know something
like that
um
yeah something like that all right
not that there are other sentences
obviously there's senses all the time
I'm just saying why it's in the story
why it's important that it's in the
story
of course there's nothing I don't think
today that there's anything wrong with
the census but we need to understand the
pattern uh as best as we can why is it
that that it would be a big deal in the
ancient world for this to exist
Lisa parrot says productivity apps yeah
yeah
it's like that some of these
productivity apps are the very opposite
of productivity because they kind of ask
you to account for all the things you're
doing and it like it can totally kill
you if you know
it's like you know I started
I started going to the gym Let's do an
example sorry I was trying to go to the
gym because my daughter wanted to go to
the gym it's like okay fine I'll go to
the gym with you so I started going to
the gym and they gave us this app with
like you know the program and then in
the app you can like for everything if
you want to you can like
put in the weight for how you use for
every rep you could put how much time it
took you and you can it's like if you
did that
my goodness like would you ever return
to the gym if you actually did that it's
ridiculous
all right
so Stephen young ass hi Jonathan do you
think it's possible that the Templars
became associated with Baphomet because
they represented a kind of ambiguous
crossing over of categories
for example the mixture of authority
from above and heaven and power from
Below on Earth secretive but also a
cultural icon
the crossing over of monastic life
particularly Knighthood and living
ascetic Glide but possessing massive
riches and banking system Etc just
curious if this Crossing of boundaries
caused people to associate them with a
disordered and bigger Spirit like
Baphomet subconsciously
sorry for the lengthy question
and so
uh no I don't think I don't think that
the Templars were that I don't think so
I my understanding about
um the Templars
is subtle like it seems like for sure by
the way the Templars have been absolved
at least
pretty much like I think it was like 20
years ago maybe maybe 15 years ago
they someone found a a letter in the
Vatican archives which by the pope at
the time which actually absolved the
Templars of any wrongdoing and it turns
out that he was the the king of France
who was really behind
the persecution of the Templars
uh and it seems like it was part of
you know
King Phillips desire to sub to also
bash the pope and to take power from
Spiritual Authority that's the way that
I see it now in terms of bafflement
what's interesting about the bafflement
and what happened at the times of the
Templars is that I think that
there's a kind of fabulation or a kind
of they made up this thing or there's
some kind of fabulation or maybe it was
based on some strange rumors because
because Baphomet strong strangely like
like it's sounds strange you like
Muhammad in in a certain pronunciation
and they were in Islamic countries and
the way they describe bafflement is a
strange kind of seems like it could even
be Muhammad and but but in a weird
distorted way but what happened
interestingly enough is that the
projection of bafflement or the
projection of this image of Baphomet
stayed with with Western history and
kind of
got integrated into Western history and
then uh became like a dream like a kind
of weird dream and you see the same with
the the um
the hammer of witches where a lot of the
stuff in the hammer of witches was was
seen fabulatory you know I'm maybe some
of it is is true but a lot of it seemed
really fabulatory but it seemed like
it's like a weird dream like projection
of your enemy or your Eve of the evil
that
that you're opposing and so it kind of
ferments in the in the culture and then
so if you look at the What's called the
taxil the taxi taxi host uh hoax which
is that in the 19th century a man named
Leo taxil wrote a book about the
Freemasons which was a taking on
a rehashing of the Baphomet legends
about of the Templars and it kind of re
made up this thing that the Freemasons
worship Baphomet and and it was like a
more elaborate version of of Baphomet
and all these all this kind of imagery
but then interestingly enough like that
type of imagery and that kind of
dreamlike thing gets taken up then by uh
by occultists and taken seriously
and then that leads to let's say modern
satanists using
Baphomet and all the imagery which which
kind of developed in this strange way as
what they are like they are the
worshipers of bafflement
uh and it's it's fascinating to see how
it happened and you see the same with
like the wiccans and stuff so it's like
the wiccans are basically taking
the descriptions in the the the uh the
hammer of witches
and are taking it for themselves
reinterpreting it but basically taking
the basic notion that that that that
described witches in those texts and are
now incarnating it at as the enemies of
Christianity and you see the same with
with uh modern Satanism so it's kind of
fascinating to see like this side how
that developed and how that that
happened
um
so yeah it's it's very particular but I
don't think that the Templars worship
bafflement I really don't think that I
mean
Bernard of clairvaux is is a pretty
tight guy like Bernardo is the man I'm
sorry you know it's like he he wrote
their chart and
you know I mean sure there was something
wrong there are things about the
Templars which which were which were off
but I really don't think that they were
but I think that the story of the
Templars and their fall is an important
part of understanding where we are now
in terms of
you know temporal Authority temporal
power trying to take over spiritual uh
Authority so
all right Matthew O'Hare says what's
your understanding of Christ having a
new name it's mentioned in the later the
letter to Philadelphia Revelation 3 12
the one who is Victorious I will make a
pillar in the temple of my God never
again will they leave it I will write on
them the name of my God and the name of
the city of my God through Jerusalem
which is coming down out of Heaven from
my God and I will also write on them my
new name
I mean what what do I think what do I
understand I think that it has to do
with the idea of a secret name or the
idea of a name which is not revealed yet
and so it has to do with the idea that
there are aspects of God which we do not
which are which are
Beyond
manifestation and that you know in the
eschaton
then those aspects will be revealed in
new names you know and and
uh you could say something you could
even say something like you we will
always be given new names in the
eschatant like you could say something
like that because
uh because because of that because their
aspects of God which
are not are are not accessible to us
let's say
so
that's what I see that's how I see it
all right Luca irimaza says what is the
meaning of vesting the bishop in front
of everyone
yeah that's an interesting one
that's an interesting one
I'm not totally sure it might have to do
with the fact that
it's like something like we are the
clothing like we are The Bishop's
clothing something like that
um
and it might also have to do with
something like understanding that the
the role of the bishop is beyond the
individual that it's not just about
so and so who's standing there but it's
like something that is received and is
beyond their individuality and so
despite their their weakness like their
Frailty
you know you can imagine symbolically
that they're not wearing clothes you see
their Frailty you see that they're not
just this glorious Bishop figure but
that they have they're punched or
whatever like they have their bodily
Frailty and that that that the the
the function they play is added to them
or is beyond their individuality maybe
it's a good way to see it
so Sean Desmond says been reading lots
of honey you know recently and I'm
finding practically everything perfectly
true and grateful okay could you give
the biggest reason why you're wary of
recommending his writings to people is
he just missing something or does he get
something very wrong well it just
depends what book you're reading my
friend I mean I don't know what book
you're reading but it's like
you know had a had a had a slight
anti-christian band in some of it and
you'll see it if you keep reading you'll
start to see it like he he
has a he has an animus against against
Christianity and it shows
he also
has weird things like he it's like when
you read it at first because you
sometimes you don't know what he's
talking about and then later for example
like he he defends martinism like his
whole career and he says martinism is a
traditional form and it's like really
and and then when you start to discover
that martinism is like
some made-up version of of Freemasonry
that was that was developed by the
French occultist Papoose you're like
okay that's weird like that's weird you
know and and then then you'll notice
that there's a bunch of
of of of other stuff that's weird like
he's he tensed for example he he seems
to want to
to defend the cathars as a possible
other tradition in the West
there's a bunch of stuff about it you'll
notice that that are that are strange uh
you know and then he he ultimately
became a Muslim and moved to Egypt and
and so he's definitely
you know it's like like I said there are
many things about him that are that are
great but it's like if you read
like if you read some of his books like
if you've read if you haven't read king
of the world yet like recreating the
world and then and then we'll talk like
because some of the stuff that He
suggests
um
I just they just they're just a little
off The Rocker you know
um
so yeah but I mean like I said I I have
deep and ratio he has he has one of the
greatest symbolic Minds that I've ever
encountered you know
you know so so on that on that front
he's he's really good but and he also
has he one of the first to have the
proper insight about where the modern
world was going and what was going to
happen so there's that but you know
yeah he he he you know he he started as
in a cultist that's important to
understand he was in the Church of
the Gnostic Church you know before let's
say kind of embracing tradition but it
seems like a lot of a lot of like a lot
of us in some ways like we kind of bring
in our old world into the new world and
so it seems like he kept a lot of that
occultist stuff with him
as he was discovering the more kind of
traditional forms and so
so there's there's so many things like
for example we said that that no
religion teaches reincarnation and he
kind of tries to explain it in some some
ways and looks at some point it's like I
see what you're saying like you're
defending against the New Age
reincarnation that kind of really
puny reincarnation that people remember
themselves as you know Prince's and
always remember themselves as in as
being great figures in the past that
kind of nonsense but but then he
it's like he also seems to to suggest
that there is no
in even in in in another tradition there
is no cycling back of the souls into
this state rather that there's only kind
of transmigration to other states but
it's like I mean he was a Muslim so I
understand why he said that that
especially if it was like a Universalist
Muslim trying to
fit Islam with other Traditions but it
seems definitely seems like like
Buddhism teaches a form of of strict
reincarnation and you see in in certain
forms of Judaism they have this notion
of the cycling of the souls where where
there really does seem to be something
like what origin or what Plato was
describing these Souls which cycle back
up you know into the
you know back into bodies for certain
reasons
um and so yeah so I don't know those are
a few reasons but there are plenty other
reasons
so
ajafka says what is the symbolism of a
priestess what would be what would their
function be
I mean so it depends on what what
religion but you know
I probably don't know enough about Pagan
religion to understand what
priestesses were in other religions I'm
sometimes I also sometimes I've wondered
if the priestesses and other religions
were priestesses
for certain gods or in service of
certain Gods maybe I don't know so I
don't really know but for sure in the
Christian tradition and the Hebrew
tradition the the Priestly role is
really a male role and so
in terms of the people and so in some
ways the priest is feminine in regards
to God and then masculine in regards to
the people uh but that but in that sense
they have to be uh a man because the
church or the body is the feminine and
the the priest acts as the head or the
the man and the church acts as that
which is receiving the body and all that
stuff
so
yeah that's why we don't have women
priests
that's also why the churches that do
have women priests they they they
quickly become
different let's just say they quickly
become particular
um not to say that there are some women
priests that I'm sure that are that are
that personally are dedicated to
Christians who but just in general when
you look at the churches that I've
embraced women priests you know
things don't go well things get weird
really fast
all right Charlie Longoria says hello
Jonathan I'm a photographer and is
wondering how I can use photography to
point back to Christ
the portrait of the human face seems to
me is a way to do that I've been in
Philadelphia and asked started asking
random people if I could take portrait
of them this was a very fun exercise
what are your thoughts on this there's a
lot I can say on this topic but I will
leave it at that for now
I mean sure yeah yeah I think you're
right I think taking pictures of human
faces is a good way to kind of point to
things you know photographer photography
is a framed action you know you frame
things and so because you frame things
it it's directed vision
and so as directed Vision you can you
can understand that it would be possible
to take pictures and to show a picture
to people that would exemplify the
proper direction or the proper vision
and so maybe that's something you can
think about
so tiered tiered says esoteric ritual
texts are often purposely veiled as
symbolism to make it exclusive
to what extent is Christian symbolism
meant to Veil perhaps you can go into
the difference in symbolism used in
esoteric satanic text and Christian
symbolism
so
so for sure Christ does that I mean
Christ clearly says in some of the uh
in some of the uh
the stories that he tells when he that
he turns then to the disciples uh and
and says that that you know it's that
now he's going to tell you the meaning
of this thing so he's like he he gives
the the story to the people
um but then he he turns to disciples and
tells them what it means and there's a
sense in which that is also
something which I think was part of the
early Christian initiative
initiatory process that is if you read
the difference in the text between uh
the the uh let's say the catech human
the catechumen's text or the texts that
are
kind of teaching the basic scripture and
the mystogogical texts which are the
texts which explain the the the the
analogies and the typology that is in
scripture you'll see that those are
different and you can understand that
that the things that would be taught to
the catechumen before they're baptized
was different than that which would be
taught to the initiated once they had
entered into the church and that the
mysteries of the the of the events would
be revealed to people as they entered
after they've entered into communion
and this is also something which seems
to happen at Pentecost which is that now
at Pentecost when they receive the holy
spirit all the things that they had been
experienced which to them had been to a
certain extent veiled were now unveiled
and they were able to see through them
into more mystical uh reality and so so
I think that there's nothing wrong with
that we have a weird idea of kind of
democratic
Democratic notion now people might
criticize me for doing Mr gaji let's say
in public which maybe but in some ways
these are strange Times Like These are
times when the normal
processes are are difficult to to hold
and so
I would say maybe one of the difference
between
um
for sure the Christian way that it
happens
and the the the agnostic or kind of
sometimes esoteric way that it would be
done this is my understanding is that
the Christian I think the Christian
images are not there to
explicitly obfuscate like they're not
meant to be completely opaque or
completely
obscure but that the initiation into
their Mysteries is like a deepening of
something that you could see at a
surface level at the outset and that you
could understand this as cycles of
deepening where the more you your
experience and the more you kind of move
into the mystery of the story then the
more you see but it doesn't negate that
which was there before it's not like uh
it's not like uh like an arbitrary code
or some these codes that this means this
this means that this means that and and
once you know that you have the key now
you can unlock the story it's more like
a it's more like a kind of deepening of
the story itself
end of its end of its implicit meanings
which which are there in in the like are
there if you're able to look with the
right eyes maybe is the way to say that
hmm
so rosberg says hi Jonathan what is the
meaning of Jesus promise about agreement
in Matthew 18 if you two if two of you
agree on Earth about anything they ask
it will be done for them by my Father in
Heaven this comes right after the
promise of binding and losing
um
well I I think it has to do with the
with this idea of
of communal bodies right of this idea
that you know if two or three are
gathered in my name that I am there
right the idea that if
if we agree
you could say like if you agree on
what's real with others then that will
be part of what makes it real I don't
want to sound post-modern that's not
what I'm doing but there's there's a
there's an aspect
to
to that
um
that by loving one another and by
agreeing together we can reform the the
world and that God will change even the
shape of the world if we
if
we
agree
um
I might do a video about that and think
about doing a video about
um
about Neil gaiman's would it dream of
ten thousand cats that he that that he
wrote and that it was in the Sandman
series
um
of how So Lisa said the past can be
erased only reframed
in a way
um she's not talking about what I'm
saying but it's related to this that
if you agree you can reframe
certain things
and it's not like it's not relative I
know it sounds like I'm saying
everything's just relative to what we
agree on but but there is a power of
agreement and love in shaping the way
the world the world exists
um of course it's like it's not it's not
idiosyncratic it can be a deepening of
reality
foreign
ers
ralstadt says hey Jonathan
what is the symbolism of Simon helping
Christ bring the cross to Golgotha
yeah I I think I think this has
this is I think this is like a promise
of what's coming in the sense that I
think that Christ is already
suggesting the church in that gesture
right already suggesting
the idea that
we will carry
the cross you know and that that there's
something you know like that weird
statement of Saint Paul that talks about
perfecting
that perfecting the sufferings of Christ
in his body that there's something about
how the church
has to help Christ Carry the Cross you
know or or participate in it
because
you could say it's something that's like
Christ lets Simon
help him Carry the Cross that's probably
a better way
to understand it uh seems like a strange
um
a strange gift right or a strange
permission that he gives but
at least that seems to be the way we
understand the martyrs is that there's a
kind of
glory in par in in the
in participating in that so
not saying that's what I want you know
so Norm gronet said just as the
formation of anybody requires sacrifice
because the things that are not that
body need to be cut off yes
does that mean that celebration always
requires sacrifice is the opposite also
true does all sacrifice bear seeds of
Celebration so
I think so and so there are two
sacrifices it's really important to
understand that there really are two
sacrifices there is the there's this so
if you have to understand Yom Kippur as
the as the the the the the atonement as
being an image of those two sacrifices
right there's a sacrifice up and then
there's the scapegoating out those two
things kind of happen at the same time
they happen at the same time on on the
cross for sure
um and so you understand that
celebration is sacrificing up right we
We Gather our attention up towards the
thing that binds us but that also
requires us uh cutting off
of that which doesn't fit or purifying
so purify yourself and sell cut purify
yourself and go to the temple to offer
sacrifice right so you cut off and then
you you gather and then you offer up and
so I think that all celebration
like any any concentration of attention
will have to will be in some ways a
sacrifice of potential attention so you
if you're concentrating on your homework
you can't listen to music or maybe you
can but you or you can't watch Netflix
at the same time right you can't study
and watch Netflix at the same time if
you do that then you will won't get good
grades because you won't have sacrificed
your attention
uh you want to have gathered your
attention in celebration and sacrificed
in the sense of scapegoated the the the
things that don't fit in what you're
trying to to accomplish
um and so I think that's true for
for all kinds of we're all celebration
so
so Nikola says what would be a proper
Christian understanding of a Nation
this question is particularly important
to me as I'm coming from a former
country of Yugoslavia where war broke
out twice in a 10-year span because the
various people claim their local
nationhood to be more important than our
previous joined one
we can see similar things going on in
Eastern Europe right now I also suspect
this pattern will keep occurring more
and more the oncoming in the coming
years and not just in Eastern Europe yes
you're right that is what's going to
happen and it's going to increase and
it's not um
it's been happening for a long time this
is this started a long time ago and a
long time ago it started a hundred years
ago more than 100 years ago
um and it it it's two opposites like
there are two opposites happening at the
same time it's like on the one hand
there's a desire to crystallize the
nation very strongly to crystallize
groups to crystallize Nations to
crystallize identities fix them very
strongly and then there's a
counterweight to that a counter reaction
which is a desire then to mix and to
confuse because we see the nation or the
identity as being too strong and too too
tight and so
we have to remember that
in the era post and after World War One
there were massive displacements of
people all across Europe and and uh and
the Middle East where
nations were now all segregated and so
all the Greeks left turkey and all the
Turks left Greece and they created these
segregated Nations that were complete
were that were as homogeneous as
possible within themselves and so
that
that is a problem and we created these
hermetic borders around states that are
supposed to contain in them these now
displaced people that have
their own common identity completely
closed off
and so
you know that was one of the one of the
reasons that justified even the
existence of the state of Israel was
this move towards saying every nation
needs their needs their land and their
country and their borders and every
group has to be closed off but of course
that's ridiculous because that's
fractally true and so you can imagine
that at every level people can now say
well we're not we're not really part of
this group like we're not Greeks we're
cretans we're not you know we're not
we're not really this group we're
actually the smaller group and so we
could fragment indefinitely uh and so
you saw that
in many in in many respects
uh but then that leads to a kind of
uh other opposite which is this this
problem of
of mixture and of wanting to to kind of
eliminate all the differences and so in
the communist
let's say time the Communist States they
had this problem where they just wanted
to eliminate nationhood and eliminate
tribalism and so they just created these
countries that contain all these tribes
inside and basically said you're not
allowed to be that you just have to be
you know the proletariat or whatever but
that doesn't work you know because we
don't exist that way we exist in these
fractal relationships so when the world
came down then everybody clung back into
their identities and now and then it was
just like my group against your group so
this is this is the problem of not
having proper normal hierarchies of
relationships across the board which is
that in a normal world you would have
people would have their families people
would have their tribes people have
their groups and then people would all
participate nonetheless in higher
identities whether it's
something like Empire but it doesn't
have to be Empire but it could just be
Christianity for example in the west you
had all these these little kingdoms that
nonetheless somehow attended to a higher
a higher good together so that they
wouldn't just constantly be at War
although they still were at word way too
much so
so I think it's gonna get worse there's
no way around it and it's gonna play on
that
on that issue you know
yeah it's a tough it's really tough it's
a tough time
so Blake straight says hey man visited
the monastery in Wayne West Virginia
last week and got to see your reliquary
during the services that place is
awesome I like to to move to the area
what practical thing do you think I
could do to make that town more of a
beacon of light
what like Wayne West Virginia
and I have a reliquary there
oh there you go I didn't I didn't I
guess I I forget like where I send my
things so I'm happy you saw uh reliquary
luckily it's important to understand
that it wasn't my Relic query that it's
the reliquary of those Saints like it
ends up belonging to the Saints you know
once the relics are in it but um the but
uh
I don't know what you could do to make
that town more of a beacon of light you
know
just uh
you know if you move there just
participate in in the in the community
and participate in the church
that's the best thing I can say so
all right guys
and so
thanks for your attention everybody
thanks for showing up and uh sorry I was
a little tired this time hopefully
nonetheless despite that there were a
few good answers in the in the Q a and
uh yeah well thanks for your support
thanks for everything guys and I'll talk
to you again very soon bye-bye